I'll start with the simple one about DSL
works a lot of people use that today as
the underlying technology that gets them
the last mile to the exchange whether
actually you know connecting to the
internet what's first by one the last
mile let's start with some basic
concepts and some of these people are
very familiar with we listen to radio
and we listen to a.m. or FM so what does
that stand for well first of all we can
do
amplitude modulation which means we have
some frequency that is a carrier wave
and we vary the amplitude of the signal
and then we can decode that in the
receiver on playback and that's the
basis of AM radio
we have frequency modulation where we
adjust the frequency based on the signal
we want to communicate FM radio we use
that all the time and then finally
there's phase modulation now that hasn't
been particularly used in the analog
space I mean what I've talked so far
about is all analog it's the way of
putting an analog waveform on to another
analog which but now we're going to talk
about amplitude frequency and phase
shift keying which is the phrase we use
when we want to take a digital signal
and represent it you know and encode it
onto an underlying analog waveform so in
the case of amplitude modulation it's
quite easy big amplitude will call out a
1 small amplitude look a lot of 0 and so
we take our digital representation and
we modify the amplitude of the signal
and we could choose more than just 0 and
1 we could choose 3 or 4 levels here and
represent several bits at a time
amplitude modulation or altitude shift
keying
we are modulating the waveform amplitude
but based on a digital signal one
frequency modulation we do the same
thing with frequency and exaggerating
here you know we could represent the
frequency 10 be much closer together
than this but we can represent on ones
and zeros that way then finally phase
keying is shift
it's called where we have a signal let's
look at the signal and then we might use
that to represent zero and then we will
shift the fears slightly together one
shifting the phase of the signal each
time we want to represent a different
bit ADSL uses all of these techniques
taken together the amplitude and the
phase we often virtue as quadrature
amplitude modulation and as a way of
drawing this for the techies out there
here's a certain amplitude at zero phase
and that can represent a value and then
at 45 degrees phase 90 degrees we go
rind and we can represent by phase we
can represent a site engine signal we
can also use amplitude at the same time
we could use two different levels and
represent a number of different values
whereas here three six from on the
middle ten sixteen altogether sixteen
different values there I think if you
were to go and look at the the epitome
of this which we'll see within a DSL on
things we're representing often hundreds
and thousands of different code points
just using amplitude and phase for many
years we tried to use simple mode ends
on the phone system and there was a
fundamental limit there and it comes
back to the way in which the digital
phone system works when the telephone
system went digital sort of in their 60s
we had to choose what digital data at
the send and it was chosen that we would
use it kilohertz sampling we would
sample the audio signal the voice signal
idea killer and we would sample it down
to it bits slightly compressed for them
it sampled at 12 bits and slightly
compressed down to 8 bits and that's the
basis of the digital telephone service
in the 64 kilobits circuit that's where
it comes from and the important thing
about the eight killer of sampling is
that another theorem called Nyquist
theorem that says if you're representing
an analog signal in a digital way you
should sample it at just over twice the
frequency and the maximum frequency of
the signal one to represent so in order
to assemble here kilohertz they had the
band limit
Linna the range of frequencies down to
less than 4 kilohertz fact they chose
3.4 kilohertz and it's one of the
reasons that you know the audio on the
phone system is different to what you
hear in real life because for different
voices it gets band-limited in different
ways has a different effect on female
voices for example at higher frequencies
and you see this Nyquist theorem you see
it applied all over the place in CDs and
dad sampling our 44 kilohertz it's
sampling at 44 kilo Hertz because it
wants to represent up to 20 kilohertz
which is you know what the human ear can
perceive between zero between 50 Hertz
and up to 20 kilohertz and so the
sampling frequency is just over twice
the bound ring but for many years then
people tried to fit in the digital
communication into this three point four
kilohertz band that was being digitized
64 kilobits and so worked very hard and
when I started out with modems it was
two signals one at 300 Hertz one at 1200
Hertz in fact I was using the BBC micro
to record touka sceptic very simple
coding scheme frequency coding scheme
used and over the years we got amazingly
cunning about using you know frequencies
and amplitudes and the phase within that
three point full coverage band in order
to get ourselves nearly up 256 kilobits
for modems and that's what that noise is
over here yes I mean looking back at
some of the old movies I don't know war
games as a classic when he was hacking
in the system's you always hear this
chirp cheep of the modem
and this is why if you listen in to a
fax today the fax still uses all that
same technology so that was great and
then the key thing is that in the phone
system we have our phone handset and we
have some band limiting technology and
then this goes off to the exchange where
it's digitized you know at 64 kilobits
per second but the signal that goes from
the handset gets limited gets limited at
the exchange and this is the the 3.4
kilohertz then well we tried very hard
for many years to squeeze more and more
bandwidth out of that so for many years
people said we'll never get about 56
kilobits and then some bright spark said
well actually if we go into the phone
line if we actually go into the copper
rather than try and put it through the
existing phone system and we tap it out
here we avoid this limit but in fact we
need to look at the copper pairs alumina
grind they have a certain frequency
response that if you try to jam signals
down them at different frequencies they
will respond differently and we often
draw a simple diagram it sort of to
illustrate this with sort of a nice
curve like this
here's the frequency and here's its
response how much does it attenuate the
signal how much does it reduce the
signal but in fact the real world is a
lot messier than that you get certain
frequencies again chopped tight
preferentially they get into feared with
by other equipment very importantly in
the grind you know your phone line
doesn't run all the way to exchange by
itself it's in there with many other
phone lines and so they actually this
cross stop between the wires so the
bright idea was had so we have some
amount of the frequency that is reserved
for the voice that's the 3.4 kilohertz I
talked about but there's all this other
space available up here so what we do is
we chop it using a technique called
discrete multi-tone so we chop it into
lots of small chunks lots of small
frequency bands just keep doing that and
then within each of those we use one of
these complex Quan codes but using that
within each of the frequency bands and
then adding it all together we can adapt
it to the interference that's present
from the other
so using this technique this has lots
enables us with the digital subscriber
loop services just over time and
suddenly break through this you know
there's going to be a 56 kilobit a break
through this and get from the 1.5
megabits of the first ADSL up to four to
six and I if we look at using very
similar technologies but now instead of
going all the way to the exchange from
home we go to a curbside box where
there's that's where the signal is
digitized and it goes over a fiber from
that sort of fiber to the curb or fiber
to the cabinets often referred to so in
my village is a big fiber comes in
terminates there with massive bandwidth
and then it gets chopped up into the
signals go to each home and because now
it's only going a few hundred feet
rather than seven or eight thousand feet
which was a very common distance to be
away from the exchange then you know the
interference and all of the other
effects it's just much reduced and so
again we can start jamming many more
bits in it in the DSP processing pallets
that's that's in your average a DSL
modem was unimaginable you know 20 years
ago that you would just be throwing it
at this problem and that gives us the
ability to get you well know I'm getting
80 megabits a second time loads am i
neither lie on the you know the new
service that's fiber to the Cabaret now
let's say we're going above that now you
need something that's going to work more
or less for asking or at least not break
things but still be understood so what
you do is you start by